son oeuvre rayonne encore à travers le
monde entier avec des dizaines
d'ouvragés préservé mais à dijon il ne
reste rien et l'ingénieur eiffel
sa maison natale au port du canal a
disparu même le pont qu'il avait
construit a été détruit gustave eiffel
est pourtant bien né à dijon en 1832 il
y a fait ses études au collège royal et
rien ne le prédestinait alors à devenir
un des français les plus célèbres au
monde jusqu'à la cage de troisième il ne
s'était pas révélée comme quelques add
rend chez tous ses camarades
mais on a beau ne pas être doué à
l'école eiffel sera pourtant un
visionnaire relevant les plus grands
défis techniques de son temps jusqu'à
construire sa tour de 300 mètres pour
l'exposition universelle de 1889 à lyon
je crois que l'aîné a dit jean effel
s'est fâché avec sa ville natale qui n'a
pas voulu les lire sénateurs en 1891
deux ans plus tard le quai du port du
canal qui porte son nom et des baptisés
l'ingénieur est associé au scandale du
canal du panama eiffel ne remettra
jamais les pieds à dijon une rupture un
désamour qui subsistent encore
aujourd'hui il ne reste qu'une avenue et
un lycée à son nom